and the key to winning florida for trump
is getting out more of the latino vote
we all know that
and when it comes to that trump has a
real fighter on his side
we have one of the greatest fighters
anywhere in the world in 4a
mass vidal champ he's a champ he's got
that heart
he's got that heart thank you man we
need more people like him i can tell you
and joining me now is ufc fighter jorge
moss vidal jorge wonderful to see you
uh we've been hearing a lot that trump
is doing better among hispanics
so are you seeing that on the ground is
it actually true
it's a red wave here it it's getting
hotter and hotter
the red wave is the real thing i mean
people waited four hours yesterday
for the rally and about 25 000
live individuals were there if that
doesn't tell you something i know
what i can tell you all i know jorge as
i kept saying today
if i had to pick one rally to go to the
one in miami would be the
most fun because everybody's dancing and
there's music
and everyone around the country is like
wait i'm they want me to be miserable
but people actually seem to be having
fun and the fun factor people have to
not ignore i think
no we we had a great time as you said
the lamp music was playing water bottles
were being handed out because we were
sweating dancing waiting for our
president to come and just give us some
words of wisdom and some encouragement
and it was a ball man and from the top
from the beginning to the end great
speakers i had a blast one of my
favorite riders
forcing donald trump this late in the
election now i know you're still
fighting but do you think you're risking
your legacy
by endorsing donald trump oh definitely
i mean we see it everywhere they try to
cancel my goya beans that i love to eat
and i've been eating since a kid that
feeds millions of latin people and they
just give charity events to when when
the hurricanes came to puerto rico they
sent tons of food over there
in places like venezuela and they tried
the cancer coach with them because they
had a
business meeting with trump so obviously
i i stand to lose a lot
but i'm not going to be intimidated by
no mob or by no individual i'm not the
type of person you could take something
from me it's better
we talk it out you know so um i don't
care what i stand to lose i'm speaking
from my heart i'm speaking for those
that can't speak
like my father like my uh that escape
communist cuba i i have to be a
mouthpiece for them you know i'm
definitely not getting more followers
or or friends or stuff like that because
i'm endorsing the president
it's quite the opposite but i i don't
care you know i honestly don't care
jorge jorge i don't know where where are
you by the way
where is that i'm at sugar factory i uh
i came to have a milkshake kind of like
an early celebration for tomorrow
okay again everybody has fun down in
florida
uh or wherever you are you are are you
in florida florida
oh yeah florida where all the fun is
jorge thanks so much great to see you
tonight